so it looks like the Patriot Act is
about to be renewed of course the
Patriot Act came to pass under president
george w bush president obama is down
with it it looks like it's about to be
extended rand paul just did a crazy long
filibuster he does one of these every
year about the NSA or about patriot act
crohn's things like that so i wanted to
talk about rand paul a little bit
because i I find him to be the most
interesting character we have in the
political sphere today because most of
them are just robots or partisan hacks
or whatever Rand Paul comes from a
libertarian background his father
obviously Ron Paul RAM comes with a
little less of the baggage that his dad
had but appeals to this libertarian
group of people that I think is a
growing constituency in the United
States it's basically people that want
the government out of your life
now of course what's odd about
libertarians and wanting government out
of your life and Rand Paul as well is
that they still have strange beliefs
when it comes to things like medical
marijuana or gay marriage now if you
were true libertarian and you believed
in people's individual liberty then and
you wouldn't care if they smoked the
joint in the privacy of their own home
at the end of the night
whether for medicinal purposes or not
and you wouldn't care who someone slept
with and married we did a story a couple
weeks ago on Rand Paul and sort of
parsing his words will annotate to it
right over here about gay marriage and
basically he was saying that the word
marriage can if if churches and
religious institutions want to have
marriage and their definition of
marriage that's fine but by the state
standard gay people should be allowed to
have something equal so I get it that's
not a hundred percent what gay rights
advocates want but he's saying by the
state's laws separate the religious
institutions let them do whatever they
want to do no matter how backwards you
may think it is but that is putting the
onus on them but let in terms of what
the state is going to do that it would
be the same some people agree with me a
lot of people didn't agree with me but I
think it's a pretty decent stance and
this is a guy who wants to become
president has to get out of the
Republican primaries and deal with all
the crazy conservatives so I thought
that was a pretty progressive stance
actually by Rand Paul but it brings me
to this thing which is the Patriot Act
and this is something that it seems to
me that most people realize has started
all of
the invasions of our privacy that we
have whether it's about our internet
history or our phone calls or the
metadata or all of that stuff this
surveillance state that just seems to be
getting bigger and bigger and the
Patriot Act gave them all the rights a
ton of members of the House and Senate
voted for it of course
Oh hugely overwhelmingly and it's one of
the biggest problems we have and this
guy's standing up for something so I
think my bigger point here is that
sometimes someone who you may not agree
it with on a lot of stuff and for those
you out there who are diehard liberals
or progressives you may not agree with
Rand Paul on a ton of stuff right but I
think there are times when someone is
trying to do the right thing that you
may not agree with all the time and that
you have to stand you have to help them
stand for that stuff ah that sounds
corny stand for RAM but you have to help
them stand for that because that's how
we actually will affect change it's not
just by constantly preaching to the
choir and only agreeing with people who
agree with you up on absolutely
everything
it's about sometimes the other guy is
not just evil and not just the bigot and
bla bla bla so I hope that this is the
type of thing where people can start
reaching across the island realize that
Patriot Act not good for us right and
here's a guy that's trying to do
something right about it so I will stand
with my hands no Jesus anyway what do
you guys think let me know in the
comments right now